oh yeah I'm lost
oh my god oh yeah an alien what happened
sounds like turn into an alien down yeah
yeah what the hell traitor I would I
would forgo traitorous activities so we
can all sorry there
I'm so sorry I was gonna role playing -
it's gonna be the alien and you're gonna
it's gonna be like hey you can't trust
me and no it's too like there's another
matter of the same thing and it today
goes green and then red I can't just do
you mark let's kill them all
get away Jesus did it I got the traitor
tell me you're welcome everybody count
Babel yes yeah it was process of
elimination go team go
losses until ten seasons think you know
what I have I have the greatest plan to
survive this no you don't no one dare
touch me
ergo I blow everyone up come on where
you trying to move I heard an explosion
alright here's mark apply Lucky's I had
a hunch - the hunch paid off yeah the
guy throwing around the corpse might be
the traitor
well I barrels coming for you what I'm
no rules
haha I am innocent
okay nobody kill me I'm in Assam hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey get away I don't see
what that she's making shitty music
together where my barrel go oh yeah
these ladders stick to my god
hope that her dress wouldn't a big
circle [ __ ] my god guy of it how I mean
I don't trust any of you solve this one
way or another who is that who is that
who is that some dude was it who's that
I'm sayin I'm gonna barrel I've got a
barrel yes not a bottle there's much oh
there he is
I'm not gonna be a part of this tsunami
go ahead
were you a part of this madness yeah
yeah thank you everywhere everyone what
Kilkenny why Ken
hey out of my office oh-oh-oh
didn't you yeah [ __ ] plain horse she
did me oh okay you guys alright god damn
it ah tingling you can sense meaning I
was the only one there go alright go
Chad oh you you guard I'll go my
innocence is pulsing my innocence oh
yeah here we go bear remain innocent
we're all innocent we're all innocent
Wow
that doesn't bode well they're not no no
keep watching
wait heading that way no no there's c4
in here [ __ ] boy
idea suggested this kind of what kind of
[ __ ] is this so we can't let ourselves
out of the tubes go in here come on
all right we want you come on no come on
come on come on lose retouches saw yeah
like I get like a big gun what do that
better Eagle so just let a sound the
best shot okay come on come on
can you guys shoot through the glass
apparently not you can't shoot us so you
got to do something in here come on
bring it bring it bring out okay
oh hey hi hi shooting shooting shooting
it was made was amazed are you shooting
no that's not get away from me is Mark
Knoller terrorist there TAS okay
everyone
okay honest I give you about his buddy
this is minxie this is the minxie
astaire job flashes dad you dumb mother
humpers you're so stupid if you believe
minx for two seconds innocent trust me
seriously he'll mix so harsh shoot that
bear who's got dinner see see you don't
dumb [ __ ]
he's a training thanks goes for two sex
dolls here's a dress boom Mele waffle as
the old Manx it must be smelling you off
it slowly shadow lady is obviously
trying to ruse you obviously it's a ruse
diction there's no one left besides minx
and LD they're both terrorists they're
both cherish happy one tears the dead
hey what not me I cannot ruse to say
you're not getting into this room you're
not getting into this room I'm
barricading the door okay Uncle Troy try
your bed well go ahead try look at this
well well well shadow lady it really is
no it's not you're gonna feel really
silly when you find out it wasn't right
that was like the smooth shout I'm
already in the tube yeah I know it makes
what did you do what did you do
she rolled a barrel at me boy I didn't
ever know
let's see you'll see oh [ __ ] she's
innocent
open up they looked in do you test on
them come on do a test on them one two
one more nasty how do you get in here we
go
okay okay test us red light red light
error that's an error because she's not
in all the way you gonna back up Lizzie
wait what who's doing Wyatt and then
close close the door okay no one of them
is a terrorist in here okay let us out
there all right
it by the way that's Olmec is a trainer
according to that like [ __ ] mix I swear
to you I hope this works
that's weird okay so there's too many of
them I don't know what I'm supposed to
do it's just too many of them